[APPLAUSE]
MEGAN BURNS: So how
is it going?
VANESSA RAY: Good,
how are you?
MEGAN BURNS: Contragulations.
What is the square root of pi?
No, I'm just kidding.
I've got some easier
questions for you.
[LAUGHS]
VANESSA RAY: You're
smart, I suppose.
MEGAN BURNS: No, I guess let's
start at a basic level, about
the storyline in itself.
I mean, is this personal
for you?
DEVYN WAITT: Yeah, it's
definitely personal.
It's not like the story of
my life or anything.
But yeah, it's personal in that
I think it's like little
pieces that I've seen from my
life and my friends' lives all
cobble together.
MEGAN BURNS: Well, it comes
off like super naturally.
And I mean, obviously, that
is due to good acting.
But how much creative freedom
did you have as an actress?
Or how scripted?
Or what's was that
process like?
VANESSA RAY: It's funny,
it does come across--
I think, when you watch it, it
all seems very spontaneous.
But it was directed.
The scenes were worked out and
rehearsed within an inch of
their life.
[LAUGHS]
It was!
No, that's a compliment.
It's good.
It means that we had time
to work on things.
MEGAN BURNS: Well, it's
super seamless.
So that's amazing.
I would never have guessed.
VANESSA RAY: Well, it's so
stylistic, in a sense, so to
really narrow in on that
and hone that in
took a lot of practice.
And Devyn's a great director.
She knew what she wanted.
DEVYN WAITT: I did know
what I wanted.
But I was talking to Megan about
this the other day, and
she mentioned that they had flew
down to Florida, and then
within a day had to become
best friends.
But I think there was also
something to taking both of
them, plucking them out of
lives, and when they first
met, forcing them to stay
together in Florida, where
they didn't know anyone.
So a natural friendship
developed between them, and I
think that helped a lot.
Because they couldn't go home
at the end of the night to
their real lives.
They were like, oh, shit,
we're in Florida.
VANESSA RAY: Yeah, we shared an
apartment and in this sort
of like, I don't know,
elderly community.
MEGAN BURNS: Because
Florida is.
VANESSA RAY: Yeah.
And I think really it was.
We had like a bottle of wine,
and just set it on the table,
and we're like, who are you?
[LAUGHING]
VANESSA RAY: Tell
me your life.
And so we truly became best
friends in like 24 hours.
It was great.
MEGAN BURNS: And then everyone
was split up for
the separate scenes.
VANESSA RAY: Which also,
I think, fed into our
relationship in the
story as well.
It was kind of perfectly
paced.
Because we were together
at the beginning.
And then she continued shooting
her stuff in Florida,
and then I went to New York.
And there was sort of like a
weird competition that we had,
in a good way.
When she came back to set, she
was like, oh, that's not how
we did it in Florida.
We didn't wear that
makeup in Florida.
And I was like, well, this
how we do it in New York!
And it really fed into
that sort of
you're-going-to-stay-there,
I'm-going-to-stay-here kind of thing.
DEVYN WAITT: It was nice.
It was actually sort of awkward
when Megan first got
back and they were a little
uncomfortable around each other.
And that was making
me really excited.
Because I like, yes.
That's like how it would be.
Even your friend that you're
closest to, that first day,
when you're getting back in the
groove of getting to know
someone, it's a little
uncomfortable.
And that just naturally started
happening between them
because they'd been separated
for so long.
VANESSA RAY: And we'd had these
separate relationships
on set with the people that we
were working exclusively with.
And so it was like, wait, so you
love that person more than
you love me?
What does this mean?
It was very interesting,
actually.
MEGAN BURNS: Right.
So in terms of casting
then, did you have
certain people in mind?
Did you know each other
before this?
VANESSA RAY: No,
we hadn't met.
But we did a chemistry test
with Megan and the guy who
plays Adam, Adam,
who plays Adam--
MEGAN BURNS: Will he ever
not play a role
that's Adam is the question.
There's a lot of Adams
in his life.
And there were several girls,
and they were all wonderful.
But it was like you had to be
dumb if you didn't see that we
had an immediate chemistry,
an immediate friendship.
DEVYN WAITT: And actually, the
character of Adam as I
envisioned him was really
different than who
Adam ended up being.
And in the same way, their
chemistry was undeniable.
And just what he brought to the
role and his presence, we
re-imagined it a little bit.
Because he came in and we
were just really taken
with what he did.
And at first, I actually was
worried that he was too
attractive.
Because I was like, oh
wait, there's no way
she's not to like him.
[LAUGHING]
DEVYN WAITT: I think that he
made Adam actually a better
character, because he's a little
more dynamic as opposed
to just being sort of--
I don't know, I think I
originally imagined Adam being
a little wimpier or something.
MEGAN BURNS: I can't even--
I don't know, maybe that is a
credit also to "Girls." His
character is a little bit
scary on that one.
So congrats for making him
not scary in this one.
[LAUGHING]
DEVYN WAITT: We didn't
even know.
We hadn't seen it.
Maybe like five years ago
or something crazy.
VANESSA RAY: I'm like,
wow, I look really
young in this movie.
[LAUGHING]
DEVYN WAITT: It was
a long process.
MEGAN BURNS: I was going
to ask that, too.
How long exactly was the sort
of process like in terms of
when you wrote it?
I'm sure it's huge.
DEVYN WAITT: I think,
man, I don't even
remember the years anymore.
But it took maybe a year and
a half to write the script.
But it was was like there was
pieces of it and ideas that
were like little sketches that
I'd written all the way back.
Maybe it was like two or three
years of thinking about it
before I even started
writing it.
And then it took us about a year
to get the ball rolling
from when Nichole came on board,
and we started saying,
OK, we're actually to do this.
And then production took--
it was a long time.
We filmed in Florida.
We filmed in New York.
And then we had to regroup and
raise some more money to film
the intro, "The Most Girl Part
of You," the prelude.
So I would say production took
about three months, three or
four months.
And then post production was
like a year and a half.
So it took forever.
MEGAN BURNS: Oh, wow.
Well, speaking of "The Most Girl
Part of You," how did you
decide on that as an opener?
Because that's an interesting
little short to have.
DEVYN WAITT: Well, Amy Hempel,
I'm just a massive fan of her.
And I've always really
loved this story.
And actually, I feel like I very
rarely re-read things.
But a lot of her stories are
more like songs or something,
where I think you can go back
and appreciate them over and
over again.
Because I mean, there's plot
there, but you're not reading
it just to find out
what's happening.
You're really appreciating all
the different words and the
little lines.
And so I had just read it.
And I was thinking, imagining
it like a movie in my head,
and really got excited about the
idea of making it into a
short film.
Because it's just such
a great story.
But then I was-- oh, they
turned those off.
That's so much better.
VANESSA RAY: You guys
have no idea.
There's like cameras of us here,
so we're both kind of
watching ourselves.
[LAUGHING]
VANESSA RAY: Sorry!
DEVYN WAITT: Anyways, yeah, I
love this story, and I knew I
wanted to make it into a film.
But I was like, uh, not certain
how many people really
see short films.
And I really have always loved
the idea of a short film
playing before a feature,
like a throwback thing.
And so once I got that idea
in my head, I started to
recognize all these parallels
between the two.
And then I think one of the
biggest reasons for me that I
really like the idea of putting
a short film before
the feature is I think a lot of
someone's experience when
they watch anything or read
anything is the frame of mind
they're in, like when
they see it.
And I think that having a short
film play before "Not
Waving But Drowning," if
someone's thinking about
whether or not they locked
their keys in the car,
anything that's in their mind
that lulls you into really
specific place.
And so I like the idea of
knowing where someone's head
is at right when "Not Waving
But Drowning" starts.
So there's all those reasons.
And then when I started to
dissect the stories, I think
they're both about
transformation and different
periods in a girl's life,
different transformations she
goes through.
It was a lot of different
reasons, I guess.
MEGAN BURNS: Yeah,
well, it's nice.
I wish they would have
that instead of
trailers, as per usual.
That's another thing I was
going to ask you about in
terms of putting it on YouTube
as opposed to traditional
screening, even if it
was small scale.
Why did you decide
that that was--
I mean, it's a cool avenue to
take because I think that's
the way that things are
going, the direction.
So to be on the spearhead
of that is amazing.
And obviously, it's
convenient.
Didn't have to get dressed
to watch it.
VANESSA RAY: That's cool,
but I think it was
probably a big decision.
Because Devyn always said from
the beginning-- she was like,
I want people to see this movie
in the movie theater.
You will see this on
a screen always.
DEVYN WAITT: Loudly.
VANESSA RAY: Loud.
Yeah, it always has
to be very loud.
So I think you should almost do
a video beforehand, say how
to watch the movie.
DEVYN WAITT: So we tried that
a little bit on our website.
MEGAN BURNS: I saw that
on the website.
VANESSA RAY: Turn it up!
DEVYN WAITT: We're like,
here's how you
should watch it--
super loud with headphones.
Well, like what she had
mentioned, I definitely
imagined when I was
first making it.
Because I've always gone to
the theater, I love the
theatrical experience.
But I think when we started to
get down into it, we just
wanted as many people as
possible to see the movie.
And I think that YouTube was
just, I don't know, something
we didn't really think about
until late in the process.
And then we're like, well,
what's really important here?
And I think at the scale we're
at, it was most important for
us to have as many people
see it as possible.
And the idea that it's
so easily shareable--
like someone could post a link
to it on a Facebook wall.
You can post it anywhere, and
there's nothing gating anyone
from watching it.
So I think we were really
excited about that.
And also I re-framed it, and
imagining how personal it is
for someone to sit on their
bed with headphones on and
watch it on a laptop.
And I think there's a lot
of beauty to that
experience as well.
And we're still continuing to
push to have theatrical
screenings.
But I think we just got really
excited about doing things in
a different way and doing things
really in line with who
we see as the audience
for the film.
And I know that there's a lot of
young girls who spend a lot
of time on YouTube.
So we wanted to put the movie
where our audience was.
MEGAN BURNS: I think its a good
little preface to coming
to New York.
It doesn't de-glamorize it, but
it says this is probably
not what's going to
happen to you.
Well, for Bed-Stuy.
Why did you choose Bed-Stuy
out of everywhere?
It's sort of the new
Bushwick, I feel.
DEVYN WAITT: And it's funny,
too, because it wasn't that
way when I wrote the script.
I mean, maybe.
I don't really know much about
how neighborhoods evolve.
But when I first moved here,
well, I first lived in
Flatbush in my friend's
grandmother who had recently
passed away's room, with all
of her stuff still there.
And that was really
terrifying.
Yeah, it was weird.
There was still newspaper
clippings that she had pinned
up, and I just had
to look away.
And then a couple of my friends
lived in Bed-Stuy.
And so it just seemed
like where the Kim
character would live.
Because it is.
I actually love Bed-Stuy.
MEGAN BURNS: It's great.
DEVYN WAITT: I go to
jazz night there.
I really love it there.
But it seemed where
she would be.
And like someone who had been
in New York for a little
while, maybe where they
would end up.
But for the adult character who
had just gotten here and
imagined, like, walking down--
I don't know, I feel like it's
not at all what she imagined
New York as.
And so I thought it was
sort of perfect.
Because it's kind of like if
you've been here for a little
while, I feel like you settle
into a place more like that.
But if you're starry eyed and
dreaming of New York, you're
like, where am I?
MEGAN BURNS: So when you first
moved here, were you waving to
people on the streets saying,
uh, I'm here.
DEVYN WAITT: Probably.
I don't know.
VANESSA RAY: I definitely was.
I was so excited to
come to New York.
And I was just like, hey!
Hey, guys!
DEVYN WAITT: Some friends.
VANESSA RAY: I was
really excited.
I definitely feel like
that was a real
slice of life moment.
MEGAN BURNS: I definitely
resonated with that.
I was asking people, which
way to Manhattan?
And there was a big sign
on the subway--
Manhattan.
VANESSA RAY: I would
just stand.
I would just stand
and look lost.
And inevitably, somebody would
come up and be like,
hey, you need help?
Yeah.
People are so nice here,
actually, if
you just look dumb.
[LAUGHING]
MEGAN BURNS: They want to
be able to give you the
directions.
VANESSA RAY: People love
to help you when
you're not very smart.
It's great.
MEGAN BURNS: [LAUGHS]
VANESSA RAY: There's a tip.
MEGAN BURNS: Yes, absolutely.
And I was also going to
ask you, can we please
talk about the horse?
I'm sure that that was a
logistical nightmare.
DEVYN WAITT: I saw Nicole.
She's here.
VANESSA RAY: What's
his name again?
DEVYN WAITT: Smokey Joe.
VANESSA RAY: Smokey
Joe, that's right.
DEVYN WAITT: Yeah.
So what do you know
about the horse?
MEGAN BURNS: Everything.
Everything.
No.
I mean, I heard from Nicole that
you did not film that in
the city, because MTA
said no, we're not--
DEVYN WAITT: They said no.
I think they laughed at her for
a really long time when
she called.
MEGAN BURNS: Can you imagine
that phone call?
Can we just put a horse
on a train?
DEVYN WAITT: Actually, speaking
of coming to the
city, like, hi, there was a lot
of stuff with production
where I'm sure Nicole
just called up MTA
dot zero, zero, zero.
Hey!
So we'd like to do this thing.
Because this was our first
time doing this
all across the board.
And I think that, actually, that
helped us a lot more than
it hurt us.
Because we are kind of naive and
just asked people things,
as opposed to having that
mentality that people were
going to say no.
We were just like,
well, let's see.
And I think it worked out.
We didn't get the
subway train.
But we got to film it at a
transportation museum.
MEGAN BURNS: Yeah, I noticed
the train was a little
different inside.
DEVYN WAITT: Stop it.
No you didn't.
[LAUGHING]
MEGAN BURNS: Not at all.
It was super real.
It was a hallucination
on my part.
So for you, was a difficult,
or was there a difficult,
scene to film?/ Because
again, it all
comes off very naturally.
But did you have anything that
made you hesitant or
uncomfortable?
VANESSA RAY: Oh gosh.
MEGAN BURNS: Or was there
something super easy?
VANESSA RAY: I don't know.
Well, I don't know.
The horse stuff was tricky,
because he would
never look at me.
And I think I had this in my
mind that this horse was going
to be connected to
me and love me.
Smokey Joe was cool, he just
was not into me at all.
DEVYN WAITT: He was trying
to the tree at the
other end of the train.
VANESSA RAY: Yeah, he's
was really into the
other end of the train.
He's like, I'm good.
This girl seems depressed.
And he just wanted
to get away.
So that was tricky, working
with a horse, I guess.
But no--
DEVYN WAITT: I actually pulled
him to you, though.
I feel like we probably
have hours and
hours of that footage.
And like everything that's good
is in the movie, which is
really, really short.
But I think at one point,
Vanessa just grabbed his face
and pulled it towards her.
And then he stopped for a
second, so it worked out.
VANESSA RAY: He finally
paid attention to me.
It's really hard.
No, I don't think anything was
particularly like, oh, that
was hard scene.
But I think there was stuff to
maneuver and figure out.
I think like the party scene on
the rooftop, that sort of,
like, semi was this a rape?
What is happening?
That scene was interesting to
figure out how we were going
to shoot it and what we
were going to do.
It was tricky.
And I was really obsessed
with weird things.
Like I got really obsessed with
how does Adele get on the
train after she's been raped.
I was so concerned that people
were going to be like, where
did she get her subway card?
It was a thing.
I was so worried, because I
was like, if this really
happened, I would need to have
an ID and a subway card.
DEVYN WAITT: I feel like Adele
would figured out, though.
I feel like she's the kind of
girl that could have no shoes,
nothing, and just--
VANESSA RAY: She did.
You know she jumped the train.
She figured it out.
But yeah, that was like
a big conversation, I
remember one night.
It was like 2:00
in the morning.
DEVYN WAITT: Someone get
Vanessa a MetroCard.
She needs it.
VANESSA RAY: Oh my God,
this girl's still
talking about the MetroCard.
I don't know.
MEGAN BURNS: Right.
VANESSA RAY: Things you
don't think about.
MEGAN BURNS: Exactly.
I don't know if you can speak
on behalf of Megan at all.
Obviously she had a different
experience in Florida.
But Sylvia's character's
fantastic.
That's super great.
So I guess, did she say anything
about how different
her experience was to yours?
Was there anything
that stood out?
VANESSA RAY: I think maybe
the pace was different.
It was really hot.
DEVYN WAITT: It was
really hot.
VANESSA RAY: It sounds silly,
but it was so hot.
MEGAN BURNS: No, it's true.
It was intense.
Her stuff was intense.
DEVYN WAITT: I'm used to it
because I'm from Florida.
But yeah, we actually had this
kid from Boston, who's
wonderful, who worked
on the movie.
And I have just such strong
memories in my head.
I've never seen sweat
actually pour.
But every image in my mind of
him working, he's got a
cigarette in his mouth, and he's
carrying something really
heavy, and his eyes are closed
because there's so much sweat
falling in his face.
And we had a lot of people that
weren't from the South or
Florida or anything.
And they were all just
like, really?
This is what it's like?
So it was definitely hot.
And also, people were really
welcoming in Florida.
Everywhere we filmed,
they were like.
wow, great to have
you guys here.
And then in New York, it was
like really, really fast.
And people were trying to hurry
us along or kick us out
of wherever we were.
MEGAN BURNS: Right.
Well, where did you film
it exactly in Florida?
It was Tampa area?
VANESSA RAY: Yeah, I'm from
Oldsmar, which is a small town
outside of Tampa.
And so that's where we stayed.
The film was actually set in
Bartow, because I wanted it to
be a little more central.
I liked the idea of the
characters being a little more
landlocked.
Because I actually live really
near the water, so it's, I
don't know, not as stifling.
But yeah, we filmed all around
Pinellas County.
And we filmed some stuff
actually in Bartow, which is
in central Florida.
MEGAN BURNS: Well, it's just
nice to have that contrast of
the outdoors as opposed to,
obviously, a big city.
I mean, I was thinking
about it today.
I was like, I don't even know
where you would find puffy
dandelions here.
I guess maybe.
DEVYN WAITT: Fun fact, you
actually can't find them in
Florida either.
VANESSA RAY: Yep.
Yep.
Yep, nope.
They don't actually
grow there.
So I think there was like PAs
that had to drive hours and
hours just to get those four.
And I had a scene where
I pick one.
And that didn't work.
DEVYN WAITT: Because the
dandelions are all wilted.
VANESSA RAY: It just
looked crazy.
So we had to-- yeah.
DEVYN WAITT: I think
I was driving near
where you're from.
I was driving in the Pacific
Northwest somewhere.
And I saw this beautiful field
of dandelions at sunset, and
all their little dandelion
heads were glowing.
And I just transported
that memory to
Florida for some reason.
So it made sense when
I wrote it.
So we were looking everywhere.
And we're like, where is this
field of dandelions?
And my uncle's actually a
botanist, and he was like,
it's not in Florida.
So I was like, we'll make one.
So there's actually only like
four dandelions in the movie,
just placed in such a way that
it looks like there was a lot
more of them.
MEGAN BURNS: That's amazing!
Well, I'll know that there's
less wishing opportunity in
Florida now before I go.
DEVYN WAITT: You can wish
on other things.
You can wish on pennies.
MEGAN BURNS: Railroad tracks?
Birthdays?
VANESSA RAY: There also
are mermaids there.
DEVYN WAITT: Yeah, there's
real [INAUDIBLE].
VANESSA RAY: We shot down the
street from a place where
there were real mermaids.
DEVYN WAITT: Yeah, Wickywashy.
There's legitimate mermaids.
MEGAN BURNS: They're making an
NBC comedy, I heard, that is a
mermaid who washes up in Miami
or something and is going to
become a bartender.
VANESSA RAY: She's
going to [LAUGHS]
become a bartender.
MEGAN BURNS: And discover the
mysteries of life at the bar.
So I don't know.
And so tell me a little bit
about the original score, too.
Because that is also magical.
VANESSA RAY: It's so good.
DEVYN WAITT: So yeah, the
composer is a good friend of
mine named John.
And I'd worked with
him before.
We've known each other for
a really long time.
And so he was always going
to do the music.
And it's actually, that's
why post took so long.
Because he's incredibly
talented,
but we're both like--
the music was always--
I wanted, obviously, parts of
it to feel almost just like
long music video sequences,
or really seamless.
I wanted the whole movie to feel
like a song, or like a
record that you like to listen
to over and over again.
And so he and I had been talking
about ideas for it for
years, even before the
movie started.
And I kind of liked the idea of
having his voice in their
intermittently, so it's
almost like a
little bit of a narrator.
When this voice comes
in, he's familiar.
VANESSA RAY: Devyn had made a
mixed CD for us, for Megan and
I, before we started filming
of just music.
And it's little bits of John's
stuff and some other songs
that she sort of thought
influenced the movie.
And that completely influenced
the whole filming
process, for sure.
MEGAN BURNS: That's
a good idea.
VANESSA RAY: It was
really cool.
I still listen to it
and work out to it.
I run to it.
DEVYN WAITT: Oh yeah,
we're going to
make a Spotify playlist.
MEGAN BURNS: Oh nice.
VANESSA RAY: Yay!
DEVYN WAITT: If I can,
I think you have it.
And I like the idea, too--
some of my favorite parts in
movies are when you can relax
and feel what just happened.
So there's a lot of little
pieces where I wanted it to
be, like maybe something
big happens between the
characters, and there's a period
of time where you can
just relax and let it happen,
let it sink in, let yourself,
I don't know, project your
own life onto it,
and then move on.
MEGAN BURNS: No, it's nice to
have process time, for sure.
And yeah, it felt like a little
Sofia Coppola-esque
there from "Marie Antoinette."
But let me just look at our
clock here.
Because I don't want to
go all the questions.
So audience, you guys have some
questions, comments, concerns?
Because I can continue
for a very long time.
VANESSA RAY: That's like
a threat almost.
I'll continue.
MEGAN BURNS: Do you want to
continue hearing me talk?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
VANESSA RAY: Yeah, two
years ago probably.
Oh, you have to go to the mic.
DEVYN WAITT: You have
a spotlight, too.
VANESSA RAY: Oh my gosh.
This is my friend
Jessica Waxman.
Hi, Jessica.
AUDIENCE: I'm Jessica Waxman.
Thank you, find my light.
So I saw it two years ago, and
then I definitely thought that
we'd be seeing it sooner.
And what was the process like
in between for you?
Was it difficult?
Did you at some point
think that it
might not have happened?
Or has it been a process of just
getting the right people
attached to it to continue
to push it through?
Because all an all, it's been
about a five year process, is
that correct?
Four years?
DEVYN WAITT: It's been long.
AUDIENCE: With Vanessa,
I think.
VANESSA RAY: What?
AUDIENCE: I just remember you
getting so excited about the
script and the film.
VANESSA RAY: Oh, I loved it.
Yeah, it's taken about
four years, I think.
But yeah, we had a first
edit, right?
And then--
DEVYN WAITT: I don't
really know what
happened, to be honest.
VANESSA RAY: And then
we edited it again.
And then Devyn had a minute
where you needed to
walk away, I think.
DEVYN WAITT: I had to get
up and just walk away.
And then we came back and
cut like 15 minutes out.
And then I was like, yeah.
VANESSA RAY: Yeah, and then
you felt good about it.
DEVYN WAITT: And then I
felt good about it.
AUDIENCE: So you need
some time to--
VANESSA RAY: There was about two
years to cut 15 minutes.
DEVYN WAITT: Yeah, there
was a little of that.
And also, we were going
to festivals.
And I think it was Nicole, who
produced, and I. So we're
like, well, what do
we do with it now?
To make a movie, I feel like
that's something I can
see the steps to.
But as far as figuring out what
to do with it-- which
now, ultimately, is put it
on YouTube for free.
So [LAUGHS]
maybe it shouldn't have been
so difficult to get.
[LAUGHING]
But we wanted to go to
festivals, and we wanted to
try all these different
things and screen it
for different people.
And we had a big screening in
Florida where I'm from.
And then we had one
in New York.
And so I think we've just been
enjoying the process of
showing it to people
little by little.
And I don't know, now it just
feels right, I guess,
to let go of it.
AUDIENCE: Congratulations
on timing and the film.
And I can't wait to see how
it evolves from here.
DEVYN WAITT: Me too.
Tell your friends.
VANESSA RAY: Thanks.
Thanks a lot.
[APPLAUSE]